hey Ron I'ma be sharp welcome to Abby's
kitchen and I'm really excited to have
my friend Abbi Langer back in the
kitchen with me yeah I'm so so to be
here but are you because we have to eat
some really terrible things it's gonna
be bad yeah I know I I'm glad that you
still like come out to see me after all
we've been through I know baby food and
like wrapping our knees and roll ups the
worst day yeah work for me yeah but
we're back and we're gonna try another
few items that you guys have asked a lot
about starting with this mushroom tea so
I hate mushrooms like I hate them so
much
I'm scared of them I know they are a
little scary sometimes right yeah yeah
but nothing is scarier than the smell
that is coming out of this cuz like a
horse's bum if I'm serious like it's so
yeah it's raw it smells like acid reflux
mixed with like puking up stomach lining
so it's like that flavor when it's like
vomit with like some just really file
right it's like smog bilious cuz it's
very sour smelling yes and it looks a
lot like mushrooms but let's talk about
this first
for I'm trying to delay I'm really
trying to and I'm warming my hands we're
really trying to buy time before we have
to like ingest it okay so but the
mushroom trend is huge right now there's
all these claims about like all these
mushroom teas and mushroom coffees like
boosting mood and improving energy and
like hearing cancer and they're
adaptogen they're adaptogen so people
will have them instead of coffee which
not stop it like no stop anything you've
done we're done really that's not gonna
have not ever
no but yeah I've got a whole blog post
on adaptogens below so you can check
that out and this particular product
from four sig Matic it's mushroom elixir
mix with reishi mushrooms reishi reishi
I think this way is that reishi reishi
reishi yeah I think it's raising so this
has 1500 milligrams of reishi which the
website tells me is really good for
supporting
sleep and stress management okay
I don't know I'm stressed just like yeah
it about drinking it looks like sewage
water so I'm pretty stressed out about
it started drinking it yeah
so some test tube studies have found
that you know reishi mushrooms may help
with improving white blood cell count
your test - yeah they're tell you
extrapolate that take you millions and I
mean yes like with humans there's beat
some like case control studies on people
with cancer in tubes if like shrinking
tumor size and things like that but
nothing in healthy adults for one and
plus this is not going to cure your
cancer so let's just put these and and
this brand is not suggesting that this
is going to cure your cancer but of
course we're seeing a lot of these
cleaning right oh my god yeah now with
blood sugar we have seen a little bit of
animal research suggesting that it may
help improve blood sugars in animals
that have type 2 diabetes that's great
if you're a rodent and that have
diabetes like not healthy and diabetic
rooted and then in terms of
triglycerides and cholesterol there's
lots of claims about it reducing
cholesterol but one big analysis of five
different studies found that it did not
impact cholesterol so there's that too
now as for the like sleep and stress
situation that all comes down to that
adaptogenic properties that people are
always always touting but I looked like
far and wide and I was not able to find
anything on the adaptogenic lowering
stress capacity of this mushroom hey the
placebo effect is it is real it is so
yeah and I would say that if this is
gonna reduce your stress it's just
because like sometimes like you know
like drinking and sipping tea is kind of
like a cozy thing for you so there's no
hug at the end of the day yeah like you
cozy up and and you're unwinding after
you know everything you're doing yeah
and it's not caffeinated so like unlike
caffeine which can of course like
exacerbate anxiety if you do have issues
with stress and not sleeping and things
like that
I guess the thought is that an uncapped
needed beverage will do the up calming I
got me well okay let's try this
it doesn't taste it tastes like poison
its oh that oh my god like if you're in
a fairy tale
and the evil witch gets you to drink
poison that's what it tastes like sort
of taste that that's what it tastes like
it's so bitter I cannot first of all
drop and give me then
thank you for sig Matic I am not
drinking that instead of my coffee
that's reaction because it's really
really really bad it's bitter as hell
you'd like people pay for that I mean I
pay for that and I'm really upset about
it I was actually super hoping when I
they were very expensive things just
like yeah I think just how much was
usually $40 I think it was let me check
my Amazon account okay honestly I'm
scared now because I feel I feel deep
Amazon regret do you guys leave Amazon
regret this is a real thing that I
experience on the daily but it's vegan
paleo included of course it is okay so
okay I'm scared how much I spent on this
please God tell me that it was three
dollars I cannot believe then you spend
$50 on this that is $50 I'm never gonna
give it back I want to cry I was okay I
remember when I purchased it I was like
oh well it's it's it's caffeine free so
like maybe I'll really like it and I can
just like enjoy it at nighttime and if a
healthy relax oh my god you're gonna
drink poison you're gonna drink the
poison tea to make up your $50 I am NOT
doing that oh my god that is that and
it's all over my facebook too for sig
Matic their eyes are everywhere I'm sure
they sell a ton of this I rhyme us but
for $50 oh my god how many do you get 20
pack 20 20 pack is that I've got a flush
era oh I don't even I wouldn't give this
to my biggest enemy no it's horrible
this is just like this be like setting
arsenic in the mail I'm sorry Orson
magmatic please do don't do that don't
do this down you know what even if it
did
all the effects that it claims to have
which it probably doesn't I was still
not sure I couldn't drink it that
couldn't knock it down if we was in a
medicine bottle people would pour it
down the same hundred percent I mean I
couldn't take it I I barely got a
tablespoon of this never mind like oh no
it's awful
yeah we need to yeah I need to just like
cleanse and I palate with like some ice
cream okay moving on to celery juice and
I've never been so excited in my life I
know I really want to actually drink I
do to get that flavor flavor it needs to
go so oh but it's really also terrible
that's so disappointing that was so
disappointing it was so gross I just
gently looking forward to some like
fling tangy and sweet and like it smells
like celery water with a little bit of
lemon like I wouldn't drink Jennifer
Anniston starts her day with her sellers
she does of course but and she actually
gets so delicious but it's gross this
was eight dollars and I'm I've really
blown my my life budget I don't they
know Christmas is going to be eight
dollars this is ruined because of the
celery juice and mushroom tea yeah so
I'm not about that
there are so many claims around celery
juice and it like boosting metabolism
helping you detox and lose weight and
less and and a lot of them are
perpetuated by this medical medium guy
well he started the whole thing did okay
so this medical medium Anthony William
guy has claimed that he is guided by
spirit not a medical degree let's be
clear on that and if that is not like
weird enough for you like his cleans
about celery juice definitely are yeah
he says that celery juice contains these
compounds called cluster salt that
aren't available in whole celery I don't
even know how that works if you're
taking a whole celery and breaking it
down to juice it should contain the same
cluster salt
yeah but coaster salts don't even exist
so I don't know yeah did you show your
did your spirit animal tell you that
yeah let's get our nutrition advice from
the fifth dimension okay so if courses
all comes down to toxins and he claims
that the cluster salts rebuild
hydrochloric acid in the stomach
binds to the toxins and then helps flush
them out you know what is funny and
sad about all of these claims is that
like all of the other like charlatans
Anthony William makes these claims that
people can't really check they're sort
of like these nebulous claims and so he
says well you're getting rid of toxins
really but there's no test for that so
you came pretty pretty much to say
whatever he wants and people are gonna
believe in and people do believe here
yeah and often like the placebo effect
is is totally so powerful it I see
scenarios yeah he also says that celery
juice strengthens your bile which is
needed to kill off pathogens really what
no bile no bile salts have nothing to do
with celery or celery cluster salts like
that is the definition of snake oil
folks yes total BS this guy completely
made this up probably in some time you
made it up not a trance yeah as for all
those claims that it's like really heart
healthy and it's gonna help you lose
weight
I mean celery has like five calories a
stalk so if you replace a meal like a
Begich or a snack bag of chips with a
glass of eight dollar water or some
celery you might lose weight kind of
cutting calories yeah but there's
nothing fat-burning about not gonna make
you lose weight just to add this into
your diet I think a lot of this comes
back to that whole myth about celery
being you know negative oh right yeah I
have a whole video about that oh my god
was an early video where I had to force
myself to eat all this celery and it was
brutal
it doesn't burn their arteries it's just
low in calories so full of water it's
full of water it's not gonna fill you up
this is like it's really this I mean I
like peanut butter right yeah that
sounds good to me
a little ants on the log action but
drinking this every single day like but
joking it down discussing - I hate my
life right now why do I do this to
myself I won't of course flag that
celery and celery juice is not bad thank
you I mean
celery's packed with flavonoids and lots
of nutrients and of course like if
you're gonna eat those in Whole Foods
that's preferred because you're not
losing out on the fiber right when you
juice it like this is a clear juice
there's no fiber here so I'm really
missing out on a lot of those properties
they're gonna help
provide that satiety factor exactly so
that's what we want to go for I say
enjoy celery if you love celery just I
guess you $8 a day I barely do it that
is all just expect it to be hydration
and move along that's it okay so next
we're gonna tackle this bentonite clay
we're gonna play I know I'm I'm actually
nervous about this but every one of
those feels like you sure you can eat it
you sure you should eat that it's bad
it's bad but yeah it's been
Banting Clay's being used for a long
time in skincare products because the
active ingredient calcium bentonite
absorbs dirt and oil in the sand so that
makes sense but now there's all this
interest it felt like eating it yeah
because of course people want to observe
their toxins that's like with charcoal
right exact same situation now there has
been some interesting research done on
animals when it comes to like IBS and
gut microflora so one study in pigs
found that those with IBS fit pigs with
IBS are you [ __ ] joking me right now
oh so but of course it has all this
interest around fat burning and fat loss
of course loss because there was one
study that looked at animals and found
then they fed them a high-fat diet and
they game this bentonite clay they
absorbed less of the fat now of course
any research gets extrapolated to weight
loss that's the Holy Grail right that's
what everybody wants and I it's
expensive I I was reading that they were
the people are hosting these clay
cleanse retreats for $2,000 a week we
need to infiltrate that oh we just show
up yeah we're here no that sounds like
absolute torture to me that's horribly
having a dip dug in yet but the idea of
consuming clay seems actually quite
disorderly Jimmy no there was a rat
study where the rats were fed a high-fat
diet and given this bentonite clay and
the rats that were fed the high-fat diet
with the clay lost weight and the
scientists explained it because that
that the clay soaked up the fat and
allowed them to kind of lose that fat
and burn that fat away well it absorbs
18 times its weight in water that's what
I'm kind of probably would become a
impressive so you literally like
literally this is clay folks so you
might actually a brick so that is my big
concern about this is like ultimately
that also puts you at high risk of bowel
obstruction and constipation I mean
absolutely sure I mean if you're having
like rampant diarrhea take something to
slow it down not sure if that's the best
option but I don't really want to have
to deal with the opposite problem yeah
and also taking clay to detox your body
I mean do we have to say it one more
time it's like the actor acting like
there's no such thing you know yeah we
tried that activated charcoal levy
disgusting it does the exact same thing
so I would be absolutely concerned that
in in the act of soaking up any toxins
it may also buy two really beneficial
nutrients like fat soluble vitamins and
things like that that you're just gonna
be excreted absolutely I am feeling a
little bit nervous about this this looks
like my father's ashes
alright be like I really don't want to
eat this it's like little pebbles of
dirt it's horrible and how much we have
to put in 1 to 10 ratio blend up to a
cup no what no it's like auntie clay
pudding he's putting the cup okay let's
just be oh oh my God look at that no
mistakes right to the bottom there wait
are we supposed to drink this yeah you
got it just no wait cows are gonna
dissolve folks so basically I assume
this is like wow I'm gonna call this
like the table or diet because my
toddler likes to play in the sandbox and
I'm sure he's consumed oh yeah they hell
of a lot of these clay and then they put
out and it's like look sludge it's not
the way to eat it should I just do it
that way it's slimy
oh it is slimy it won't come off the
spoon no okay can you just it's like if
you made couscous and then let it sit
there to gelatinize and then you soak
that couscous in water to get it a
little bit more moist like
it's dry why don't you just go outside
when it's raining and lick a puddle no
[Applause]
today's nothing my best day Oh somebody
get me the Herbalife seriously I'm
worried it's like sticking it feels like
you know if anyone that's had braces
before and had to do like moles if their
money yeah exactly what it is oh it's
awful it's awful and it's I mean ah I'm
also upset that I ate and I bought that
how much did I spend on huh I hope you
didn't spend more than $2 on this yeah I
look at it you look like solid cream of
wheat this is actually all gonna
dissolve I need a napkin
that's sick how much okay $13 sorry guys
so disgusting is your mouth really dry
now it's so dry they also think in my
breath yeah okay but like seriously
folks this is like not only absolutely
disgusting but potentially dangerous as
well one study found that people who are
taking clay products and it with like a
ton of terrible side effects like
diarrhea and bloating and constipation
and gas like no Cheryl I wonder why
literally eating like dirt not just dirt
it literally reminds me of kitty litter
yes it absorbs it's like yes all the
water I pay this is king kitty litter
it's not worth it this is so not worth
it no matter what you want to bind it's
yeah no I'll worth it tastes like not to
mention the FDA I saw issued a warning
about clay products and some of them
being laced with a lot of
lead and arsenic so this is probably
dangerous yeah I'm not in this one it is
I don't know that anything about this
particular brand or product all I know
is that it's King disgusting
like who I don't even dissolve this it's
not there's only it's like sticking the
puree into a smoothie if you if you just
hate your that does not eat it ever
Katan and let's pass so finally we are
going to be kind to ourselves and talk
about something that we don't have to
consume yeah raspberry coulis
because let's be real I read the
research I spent $25 on this on Amazon
and I would like my money back
and that standed yeah back so I'm not
gonna open it but these guys have been
around for like so why people still talk
about raspberry talking about it I see
it all the time it's one of those things
that are is really really popular in
search engine like when I when I look it
up it's like so many hits and I don't
know if it's kind of made a resurgence
because of the whole keto diet came out
and ketones keto sounds like kinda the
same thing but it's it's not well I
looked at that further evidence I looked
high and you're gonna have to look
really really hard there wasn't like
petri dish inand rat cities that found
that it may have some fat burning
potential are you a petri dish no you're
not okay I know more about a petri dish
but also you'd have to consume like a
hundred times the volume to get the same
effect that they got in the Patriot
there at all so I don't think we're
doing that that also sounds super
dangerous right so the one study that I
was able to find on humans had people
dieting exercising taking Raspberry
Ketones and other supplements and they
lost weight wow that's
there's no confounders no no compounders
but like yeah so like was it the
raspberry magical raspberry ketones or
was it like the back-breaking exercise
and restriction that you've imposed on
yourself to guess is raspberry ketones
really kind of absolutely no evidence to
back them up this is an expensive
product this was 25 bucks
for basically nothing it's a source of
antioxidants just like consumed a
healthy relatively balanced diet and
also you'd have to keep taking that yeah
so how about a twenty five dollar bottle
of raspberry ketones for right
you know like who's gonna do that I know
unfortunately I think people do I know
they do and the thing is is that when
you were consuming a supplement like
this and you are exercising and you are
dieting and you are like there's all
these different pieces of the pie yeah
there is no way for you to even know
what is actually making a difference in
your lifestyle if it is making you feel
better so I would say this one takes a
hard pass
save your money there really is no
evidence to suggest that these guys work
and just it's such a waste of money to
waste
so I'd say today's selection of goodies
was a big epic failure total fail there
is not one day like no the clear that
the clay is what got me in my dreams
yeah that was the mushroom tea like I
don't know it's a toss-up between the
clay and the made me upset about the
price of the mushroom tea if the
mushroom tea was like free I wouldn't be
so upset yes you would because it tasted
like [ __ ] it looked like diarrhea water
it did so on that note we're gonna close
off here and like rinse out our mouths
and have some real coffee I think you
might like maybe a mimosa or something
like hard I need so much bubbly like
champagne that's something I just need
to collect basically cleanse that out of
I need to cleanse from my cleanse yeah
that's that sounds good yeah yeah so
let's work on that and in the meantime
if you guys have any products that you
want us to try out in review leave us
comment below if you like this
collaboration leave me a comment below
also check out Abbey's website she's got
an amazing Facebook and Instagram I'm
gonna leave all those links in the
description so you can check those out
and as always subscribe to the channel
give this video a thumbs up share it
love it and I'll see you next time on
copies kitchen bye
[Music]